there's a British girl who has gone
viral for describing an experience that
she had in the gender neutral changing
room which she says she supports by the
way because she's so politically correct
and liberal and open-minded intolerant
but despite all the wonderful promises
about how gender-neutral bathrooms are
going to lead to Greater equality and
flourishing for everybody that's not
what happened
so I was just in Primark in Cambridge
and um
I feel really stupid being emotional
about this but
um
yeah I was trying on some clothes and it
was a unisex changing room which I'm
really full and I love that because you
know it makes everyone feel included but
twice
um two men walked opened the curtain
walked in on me
um luckily but at times I had I was
wearing fully clothes but I could easily
not have been
um and I yeah it was two different
people
um clearly from the same group and there
was many like probably like 100 changing
rooms available
um so it's not like you know it was like
always someone in here or not it was I
mean you know clearly
um yeah I just want to say to people
please be careful
um and if you go in the changing room
try not go on your own
um I will never be doing that again I
would rather take it home try it on and
then take it back and get refunded
this woman is never going to try on
clothing in a store again
because why
Why Can't This Woman do a really basic
thing involved in shopping for clothing
because men are now allowed to get naked
in the same rooms as women and the only
men who are doing this by the way are
mentally ill men who think that they are
women and who have bizarre sexual
fetishes and desires and it turns out
that those mentally ill men with bizarre
sexual fetishes and desires sometimes
behave sexually inappropriately and pull
the curtain open on women as they change
who could have guessed wow stop the
presses we got a man bites dog story
here folks
no we don't of course this happened
and why are we even in the the position
in society where this can take place
where this woman could be victimized in
this way because we've indulged all
those completely insane premises and why
have we indulged those insane premises
because we were told by the the liberal
brainiacs that actually men and women
aren't different and even though they
seem different in every way even though
not in every way there are similarities
between men and women but even though by
all of our senses we can tell that there
do exist differences between men and
women and those differences are
significant
we have to deny that reality we have to
ignore reality because of their Egghead
Pie in the Sky ideology they're they're
wonderful utopian idea that men and
women are exactly the same
and if the reality doesn't match the
theory
it doesn't mean that the theory is wrong
it means that we have to deny reality
and so now we can't go shopping anymore
we can't go shopping can't use the
bathroom we can't we can't you can't
send your daughter into a changing room
at the public pool because you know
there's very possibly going to be some
creepy dude in there with some bizarre
sexual Hang-Ups waiting to prey on them
so what do we do do we change the rules
do we tell the liberal Eggheads that
they were wrong
do we tell the men to stop putting
dresses on and to start dressing like
men and to start behaving
no no we just allow Society to crumble
and we lose all of our nice privileges
that we all enjoyed in our nice way of
life and we lose that because of a
theory that's preposterous
I mean I'm beginning to think we do we
need gender clinics you know on the
right we've been we've been now saying
that we need to get rid of all these
gender clinics certainly the Pediatric
gender clinics but the adult gender
clinics too you know where a man goes in
and he he gets a doctor to chop him up
and make him look more like a woman I
think we need gender clinics we need we
need many more gender clinics in America
here are the gender clinics
if you're a woman the gender Clinic is
they already exist but we need more it's
called The Beauty Salon
and for the man that what is the gender
Clinic the gender Clinic I don't know
it's a cigar bar it's a gymnasium it's I
don't it's these things already exist if
a woman goes in to the doctor says doc I
feel like a man I think I might be a man
you know and I want to dress like a man
and cut off my hair really short like a
man and even chop up my body the man is
going to say oh the doctor is going to
say okay ma'am I'm prescribing you one
trip to the female gender clinic and uh
I I'm going to prescribe you a mani pedi
and a nice hairdo and a little bit of
makeup and then you're gonna go there
and you're going to look more like a
woman and and probably feel more like a
woman and you are going to do your duty
and your responsibility if you're a
woman to behave like a woman and if
you're a man to behave like a man that's
the gender Clinic I want to I want a
federal law Congress get on it
speaking of
reactions against this kind of crazy
crazy stuff
the the greatest news right now
in international politics is coming out
of Italy and that would be the Italian
elections last night the Italians have
elected a conservative
government led by a woman named Georgia
Maloney
how do you know that Georgia Maloney is
great you know Georgia Maloney is great
because the Atlantic is calling her a
fascist you know that Georgia Maloney is
totally spot on the money because the
libs are losing their minds and they're
doing what they do anytime anybody to
the right of Hillary Clinton gets
elected anywhere they're saying this is
horrific it's Nazi it's fascist it's
racist it's this is it's thatist it's
undemocratic yes that's right more
people voted for this lady that voted
for the other people but and that's why
it's undemocratic because the people
voted for her well so what has she said
that's so fascist and Nazi and racist
and terrible here's what she said I will
translate for you a beautiful little
speech from Georgia Maloney
this is what we're doing today why is
the family
why is the family
it's a single answer
because it defines us because it's our
idea
because everything that defines us is
for those who don't want us to have an
identity anymore and to be perfect
consumers
so they attack national identity
they attack religious identity they
attack General gender identity they
attack family identity
I'm not allowed to Define myself as
Italian
Christian woman
I've got to be citizen X gender parent
one parent two I've got to be a number
because when I'm only a number I don't
have an identity I don't have a Roots
I'll be the perfect slave
at the mercy of financial speculators
the perfect consumer spot on the
freaking money spot on the money and she
goes on later in that speech
I can't believe there's an Italian
politician quoting this man she goes on
to quote GK Chesterton the Great British
conservative a hero to American
conservatives
a hero to Christians I hear it a
Christian conservatives especially
she goes on to say no we're going to
defend our families we're going to
defend our way of life we're going to
defend our countries against the
predations of the Davos set the great
resetters the the people who want to
erase our borders erase our identity
erase our culture erase all the things
that we hold dear and and make us all
live in this clinical generic sexless
nationless
familyless dystopia where we're all
living in ba in pods and eating bugs
we're not going to do that
okay you know what uh the conservative
who's in a coalition government with
this lady because you know the way the
way politics Works in Italy it's not
like there's just two parties and one
wins and one loses there are lots and
lots of different parties and so this
government that's going to be led by
Georgia Maloney has got other
conservative parties in it one of the
leaders of one of those conservative
parties the Lega party
is this guy Matteo salvini who I love
he's just like a big happy Italian guy
and he'll tweet out pictures of
spaghetti bowls of spaghetti I've
actually seen this pop up in my Twitter
feed and I love that he does that this
is the kind of appeal that people want
to see in politics and that people ought
to make in politics
I don't want my politicians to give me
some stupid Egghead spreadsheet
five-point plan of some utopian abstract
technocrat nonsense I want politicians
to realize that what do I really what do
I really want from my politicians I want
them to protect my bowl of spaghetti I
want them to protect my way of life my
traditions my culture my family and my
community okay and I don't want some pie
in the sky plan on how we're going to
upend everything and innovate everything
and get rid of borders and we're all
going to sing Kumbaya as citizens of the
world no protect my spaghetti protect my
family this woman Georgia Maloney she
says we've got a simple mandate here
okay we are we are running for God for
family and for country
okay those are the important things to
us not for Davos not for global warming
not not for socialism not for any of
this crap okay we're running for God
for family and for Country beautiful I
want you know I say I don't make
endorsements in the primary elections in
America as of right now before we've got
any declared candidates for president of
the United States in 2024. Georgia
Maloney has my support right now if we
can figure out a way
to make Georgia Maloney a citizen of
America and to amend the Constitution so
that you don't need to be a natural-born
citizen I
I'm so inclined to support this woman
for president whoever the Republican
nominee is in 2024 I want you to read
her speeches verbatim okay
she's great
if you look on Wikipedia right now
Wikipedia says that she's a far right
hard right candidate and why
I don't have the text in front of me but
you can go look it up on your own I've
roughly what it says is because she she
opposes abortion
she opposes euthanasia that is assisted
suicide
she supports National borders she poses
illegal immigration
and and she opposes same-sex marriage I
kid you not that's one of the main
issues that Wikipedia cites as to why
this woman is far right hard right
insinuating that she's a fascist
because this woman holds the view of
marriage
that Barack Obama held in 2011. that's
now considered hard right far right the
view of marriage that every single
person on planet Earth held for all of
human history until roughly 2015.
the view of marriage that Barack Obama
one of our most left-wing presidents
that we've ever had held as recently as
11 years ago
now if you hold that position you are
considered hard right far right fascist
nazi and so those words mean nothing
Nazi doesn't mean Nazi when the libs use
it fascist doesn't mean fascist when the
libs use it in fact when I see those
words hurled at conservative politicians
by the dishonest left-wing media I just
assume it's a great politician
because I know the one thing I know for
sure is when the libs call you a Nazi or
a fascist you're you're for sure not a
Nazi or a fascist so what is it just
means that you have any kind of inkling
toward a serious type of conservatism
not the squishy lame fake Liz Cheney
kind of conservatism you know just maybe
cut taxes and bomb the Middle East kind
of conservatism no no deep conservatism
support my family support my country
support my traditions support National
borders real conservatism you know in a
world of Liz Cheney's be a Georgia
Maloney I'm so glad you like that clip
now like subscribe Ring Ding Dong get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]